hi my name's Samuel Leeds and in this
video I've got eight ideas that maybe
things that you've not thought of maybe
things that will surprise you things
that you probably should be considering
if you're starting out as a property
investor number one is to rent out part
of your existing home now you might
think what are you crazy why would I
want to rent out but here's the thing
and this might not be for you but if you
you've probably got space in your house
to rent out a room or something in your
house and let me tell you why this is so
powerful number one and please check
this out with an accountant I don't want
to be sued or anything I believe it is
tax free up to a certain amount I think
it's like seven or eight thousand pounds
so you can if you rent out a spare
bedroom in your house the money that you
get if you're yours to keep even spend
it you'd have to pay tax on it up to a
certain point which is really cool but I
think the reason it's so powerful is we
had a lady we'll call us Sarah because I
don't know she'd want to be made known
she came on to our crash course program
two days and she just said I just don't
know I'm a bit scared about property I
don't understand there I've never done
it and I spoke to her once you decided
to do what she decided she lived in the
center of London or near the centre of
London and she had a spare bedroom in
her apartment and she decided to rent
out the room in her apartment and she
rented out for 700 pounds a month and
she said that that money from just that
spare room that just had clutter and
stuff in it she said it was life
changing you know life change it a
700-pound might sound like a lot of
money it might not - you wish it was
completely life changing and I only was
that money life changing I made her life
a lot easier
because now suddenly she wasn't going
slightly further and further into debt
each month because she could pay her
bills comfortably and relaxed and go out
and not only not only that but also she
said that she understood tenants and
property investing more because she
similarly moved someone in sign a
contract with nan it gave her a real
confidence and she saw money from
tenants she then got the book for it and
once she had the bug for making money
from renting stuff out she went on to
get some rent to rent deals and also
she's now bought a place to rent out
because she saw the power of rental
income so I think that if you're
starting out renting out a space in
house is a really really good idea
number two is consider moving area now
I'm not talking about you moving house I
mean maybe you might want to do that but
I'm talking about you've probably got a
preconceived idea in your mind of where
you should be investing now you might be
thinking that you have to invest in your
hometown or where you live but actually
you don't have to because your hometown
might be a rubbish investment area as
long as you have a management company in
place where you buy then it doesn't
matter so potentially just open your
mind up to moving out into a different
area where you're currently thinking now
I spoke to one guy he lives in Belfast
and in his mind he was thinking I have
to invest in the Midlands middle of
England I had to invest in the middle of
England and he was thinking that because
that he knows that's where I'm from and
he just thought oh well to be an
investor do you after you invest we're
sad you're its paste we just complete
nonsense and actually I spoke to him and
I said Belfast is there's a lot of
opportunity there so now he's now moved
to Belfast where he lives
so sometimes your own area can be a
really goldmine area but it's just under
your nose and you don't see it just be
open to moving area of where you're
thinking to invest number three is to be
creative with maximizing rent so what I
mean by that is if you're starting out
as a property investor you might just be
thinking in the mindset of a buy a
family home I rent it out yeah it can be
much more lucrative and exciting than
that you can maximize the profits of the
rent by doing things like renting out on
a room-by-room basis which we call a
mortar or hm app or renting the property
out of serviced accommodation be
creative about how you can maximize the
rent when you're looking to buy number
four if you're starting out in property
I speak to a lot of people in fact there
was a one lady who I met good friend of
mine she came along to the crash course
and she said Samuel I'm skint I've got
no money I'm really struggling to even
afford to just pay the bills I've got
four kids and I can't invest in property
you know and I had a little conversation
with and it turns out that she had
almost paid off her mortgage to me if
you've almost paid off your mortgage
you've got money now in her mind she's
thinking you know she's all alive she's
been told by a parent she has to pay the
mortgage off as quickly as possible and
she's still not even paid it off but in
my mind I'm thinking why don't you just
refinance your house and pull out the
money she had three hundred and fifty
thousand pounds equity in the house and
saying I'm struggling to live on the
skin I can't do property after a little
conversation she realized lightbulb
moment that if she refinanced the money
from her house and pulled the equity out
and then reinvested that into properties
although she's you know obviously
further off paying off a mortgage
she's similarly got way more cashflow
monthly cash flow and sometimes people
felt I don't want to do that because
then the money that I've pulled out the
house I then lost it you haven't lost it
at any time if you wanted to you could
sell off the investment properties and
put it back into your own home and in
fact by the time you've done that and
sold them the house prices would have
probably gone up and then you'd pay your
mortgage off and some it just makes
sense so potentially you're sitting on a
home where you've got equity in there or
you might have a family member who's got
who's got me so just think how can I
raise finance to invest in property do
you have assets do you have stocks bonds
shares dividends do you have a company
that you can potentially sell do you
have things that you could sell could
you down sites and sell the house could
you refinance the house do you have
partners or family members that I've got
money sitting in the bank that you can
invest for them so it's just thinking
creatively about what you can do with
your money now of course you're going to
need to know how to invest that properly
so I'm not suggesting that you just go
crazy and become a motivated idiot
because there's nothing more scarier
than I motivate idiot but just think you
know have I got on tap money that I
could invest number five is become a
window shopper for property sometimes
people get scared to book viewings and
go out because they think oh my gosh the
estate agents gonna press them into
buying and I'm gonna be ready to buy and
I haven't just relaxed books and
viewings maybe in your hometown or in an
area where you're thinking of investing
in and just go and view some houses and
have some fun see it as a day out you
know what make friends with the estate
agents most estate agents they're not
like property experts they're just young
fun friendly people I even used to be an
estate agent I don't if that's a bad
thing just go in and view houses and
when you're doing that and you're
looking at properties and you're talking
to agents and you're beginning to
understand the market yes the estate
agents you know they won't give you
really good investment advice and they
won't even show you the best deals and
things like that but hey it's free and
it's fun and you should be doing it 100%
if you're starting out in property
number six is if you're starting out in
property maybe consider buying a deal
from a deal saucer so someone who's
packaging it up for you if you're going
to do this I would say just because
someone's packaged
and they're charging you two for the
deal does not necessarily mean that it
is a wonderful deal it's probably better
than you could have found if you're just
starting out and you don't know what's
what but make sure if you're doing that
number one the deal sorcerer has a good
track record number two the deal
sorcerer is compliant and number three
just go with you got feeling a little
bit not only the deal sorcerer but just
generally what the kind of deal is
because ultimately if you're buying it
you're responsible but I think it's
definitely a smart decision for busy
people that are in jobs that don't
understand the market that well they
don't really understand properties might
not understand all the different areas
it makes sense to pay two or three
thousand pounds to have somebody find a
deal negotiate the price down package a
team get ed power team around it just
makes sense
definitely something good to consider if
you're just starting out in property
number seven is go to property events go
networking go and meet people that are
doing it the reason it's hard for people
starting out is because no one that they
know none of their friends are investing
in properties successfully and if it's
something you don't know and you don't
know people that know it either then
it's like almost foreign whereas if you
go to property events I mean we've run
something called the property investors
circle you know there's pin meetings and
people yeah there's all different types
of property mix that go on across the
country so I would just say get down and
have fun and talk to people their
language if property investing will just
begin to become something that's a
little bit more known to you which will
mean that it's less daunting when you do
buy your first investment property and
lastly number eight is I would strongly
advise to get trained oh I'm a property
mentor you can always reach out to me
I'll run something called the property
investors Academy which is a 12-month
program but just get knowledge you know
if you start a name property the number
one suggestion would be before you
invest in property invest in yourself
because that's something that no one can
ever take away from you and you'll be
able to use it again and again and again
and again when growing your portfolio so
there are my eight ideas for people just
starting out in property I hope that's
been really helpful if you found this
video useful please do drop it a like
maybe leave a nice comment below and
share the video I'd really really
appreciate that
and I hope to meet you in person real
soon god bless see you next time thank
you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course
watch this video see what happens but
whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time